I remember one time I went to the strip
club it was like oh man it was like 26.
it was a stripper there she was really
hot and then uh at this coffee shop I
saw her and I was like oh [__] I know
you like people think that I'll like be
embarrassed you know if you see someone
at this trip like how many guys would be
embarrassed you see a stripper that you
were at a strip club with and then you
saw them later on in real life you go oh
I don't wanna you hide from them like
it's your teacher at a grocery store
not me dude I walk right up to that
person hey teach
or hey I remember you and they go oh
yeah oh hey I say hey what's up we
should I remember the man I was I must
have been 28 or something
I wish you had some time what's your
number dude she gave me her she goes
like all right here give me your phone
and she typed in her number and I go ah
cool and then I looked at it later and
it was like [__] it started with like a
two no numbers it was fake
it was like two five six six six six six
six six six six six six they were like
25 sixes in it and I go oh man I
certainly been hadn't I